Well what can you tell us about...?
Okay. *laughs and claps hands*
You're the first person to ever ask me that.
Yeah.
And I do have some news that
nobody else knows. The reason being I only got this news...what day is today? What's today, Friday?
No, it's Saturday.
Saturday.
So we got this I got an email on Wednesday.
Okay, let me tell you what's happening to me next week.
I have to leave here on Sunday, but which I don't want to I would love to stay for...to see more of this.
It's amazing. On Wednesday, I go to New York for, there's a Comic Con in New York,
not for Game of Thrones for something else and
then on Saturday I get on a plane from New York back to Ireland. I
run into my house for 20 minutes, say hello to my family
and then I get in a car and I go straight up to Belfast where we are having the first, do you call a table read?
a read-through?
No, a table read.
We have the first table read on Sunday of the
of
three episodes on on Sunday, and then on Monday we read the next three.
And that's so that's Monday, then we have then we rehearse
for the rest of that week with their
two of the directors.
There's three directors for the final six,
And then we start filming, I think, officially it's either the 16th or the 19th of October.
So what's that three weeks time? (Yeah.) Three, three, three weeks time we start.
And that's that's real news.
That's real news. Now, I have to check with HBO if I could tell you, so that that's proper. It's proper news yeah.
So nobody else, so nobody else knows that.
That's good news though.
It's very good news.
Yeah, absolutely and speaking about the, the last season...
Yeah.
Would you rather
die in a spectacular way...
Why do we keep talking about me dying?
Your character better than...
Why don't you ask?
Why don't you ask what I'll do when I'm sitting on the throne? Why don't you ask that question?
But would you rather die a memorable death or
to be just in the last frame of the last episode of the last season of Game of Thrones?
Oh I think, I think what should happen
is we should take the throne when I'm finally king, (Yeah) and bring it over to eh,
Dorne. The wine is really good.
It's like Tuscan wine. It's beautiful. It's like Tuscany wine. And myself and maybe
Missandei could retire
quietly
to Dorne.
What if I'm right? If I get, I'll get in terrible trouble if I say I think it's
this and they go "you idiot you told them" and I go "Oh well I didn't know. It's just a guess."
Cuz I got cuz I got in trouble before, cuz eh, last year. I got in trouble
because somebody asked me when is the new season coming, it's going to be late and
I said I think it's gonna be around July and I got phone calls and
Twitter went mad. They said "Davos says it's coming out in July." not my, and I went, "oh Christ"
And the reason, I guessed, because we started three months later. We started filming three months later
we finished three months later, and I went it's probably gonna come out three months later, but the problem was I was right and
They hadn't announced the date so I kind of struggled, so I'm not guessing. I'm not saying. No way.
So when we'll be able to to watch the eighth season of Game of Thrones?
No, just because it were...
I have it on a stick. I have it on a USB.
There's one for everybody!
When? Well I mean if you have to think of it, this, it's going to be a huge season and
there's various rumors about when we're stopping and
they're not quite sure yet because of the size of the season
but it's going to be summer next year before we finish and it's for six episodes.
So these, as far as I know, all the episodes are gonna be really long. That, to the best of my knowledge.
Um, some people are saying feature length but, uh,
but we're spending a lot longer shooting six than we have with shooting ten, so, this year. So,
so that's gonna make things go later.
So if it goes to the end of summer and with the amount of post-production with, with obviously with computer stuff and and everything else
It's, it's very unlikely you're gonna see it next year. I mean you could but it would look shit.
So to make it look as beautiful as we've made it look in the past. It's looking incredible.
We don't have a date, but it's increasingly looking like it's going to be 2019, but we haven't been told.
I'm, I haven't even been given
We're doing this script reading on tomorrow, one week, and I still haven't been given the script. I'm getting them
I think on Monday or Tuesday. I'm going to have the new ones on Monday and Tuesday whew!
Hey everybody!
Thank the Lord of Light for ser Davos because he just explained
exactly what's gonna be happening with season 8. What their timeline is. What the episode
schedule is going to be. It sort of backs up the claim that the episodes will be
vastly longer than before. Remember, 15 million dollars per episode. So I'll explain what all that stuff
he just said means, because a little bit of it was tongue-in-cheek.
So if you're finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything.
We'll be doing Game of Thrones videos until season 8 gets here, and they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of the video too.
So this interview actually happened a couple days ago from the day that I'm posting this, but he basically says that next Sunday
he's going to be getting the first three scripts,
they'll be doing the table read with all of the actors. Like they'll all be sitting in a giant room going through the first three
episodes. Then a little while after that, that following Monday, they'll do the same thing with the final three episodes.
And then a couple weeks after that they'll actually start filming. So that's actually happening right now.
He pens their official start date to where like everybody is standing on set together, cameras are rolling around October 17th,
give or take a little bit. And the finish day probably being at the beginning of the summer, which would be late June.
So when he talks about how it might take till 2019 to get the episodes out, he's talking about post-production.
Because this year it took them about five months to turn things around. Just for a reference,
Emilia Clarke wrapped season seven around February 3rd.
They officially wrapped everything else just a little while after that. So it took them about five months to do
post-production for all seven episodes.
Presumably they finished the seventh one as the first one was airing. So because he says that they're filming way more footage for six
episodes than they've ever done for ten episodes in previous seasons, they're spending fifteen million dollars,
and there's some production challenges that also slows things down a little bit.
It sounds like
post-production is gonna stretch a couple more months than it normally would. Which you know means that they might be able to squeeze it out
by the end of 2018.
Really the holdup,
I think, from a CG perspective is just having three dragons in every single episode or almost every single episode.
Like think of episode four and episode six, where you had a lot of
dragon action. The camera was on the dragon for a long period of time.
Facial replacement, like when they did the big Arya-Brienne fight?
They had to swap her face with the stunt doubles face. That takes a little bit longer. In a really big
Hardhome Battle of the Bastard style episodes where you have giant, wide crowd shots. And even though Davos didn't say it Nikolaj
Coster-Waldau in a separate interview
talked about how they can't rely on their second and third filming units as much. So a lot of times in previous seasons
You'd have the dragon unit or you'd have the wolf unit filming in completely different parts of the world simultaneously
for scenes in the same episode. So it meant that they could film episodes twice as fast.
Especially when they had three units going it was even a fourth unit called the White Walker
unit during season six. So the more film units they have shooting scenes
simultaneously, the quicker they get things out. They can't do that as much this season because for the most part
everybody's in the same place. You have everybody
converging on Winterfell.
And then you have a couple people down in King's Landing, for at least most of the season.
Remains to be seen whether or not Cersei is going to end season 8 down at King's Landing.
But I think that would be fitting. That's a little bit of
speculation though.
Her life feels like it's been so tied up in the game of thrones, in the quest for the iron throne, for so long it
would just make a lot more sense that her story ends at the iron throne.
So I'm not expecting her to just hightail it all the way up to Winterfell, to where everyone else is.
There was also a funny nod to some stuff that was happening during season seven that people were speculating on between
Davos and Missandei. Because he got really funny with her.
He would ask her weird questions, like is he hitting on her? What is going on?
It's almost like he's trying to drum up some chemistry with her or something.
"Missandei of Naath."
"Ser Davos. Lord Snow"
But I don't think that that was the way that it was written
I think that was just Liam Cunningham trying to be charming in the scene. Like
he just has a way with people. He's a very charming person when he's not telling everyone that they're royally screwed.
"What if someone takes the boat?"
"Then we're fucked. Best hurry!"
But I do like his idea of him surviving with Missandei and taking the Iron Throne
down to the beaches of Dorne. Just to lounge around and drink their fine wine for the rest of his life.
So I guess that would mean that they'd have to unsink Dorne from the sea, because as of right now
I think the producers are just hoping that you forget about Dorne altogether.
Like you know that was a storyline that didn't work out the way
we wanted to. Maybe you just forget about it and focus on what's going up way near Winterfell and the army of the Dead.
But I think what'll happen is, is once they start filming. They'll actually have a better idea of how much longer
It's going to take them to finish and they can get stuff into post-production. If it does look like it'll definitely spill into
2019, then I think that HBO will probably try to do some special
promotional stuff next year in addition to the big live concert event that they're doing, so that they can just throw
fans a bone. Like, okay,
you know, we understand that you're waiting a long time, but we're gonna give you some new form of Game of Thrones.
But the cool thing is, is that the Game of Thrones composer,
that's doing the live concert, has a couple months break that starts at the beginning of the summer.
Meaning that that's when he'll probably start scoring the final episodes. I think they're cut off for 2018
will be like if they could finish all the episodes and start posting them by the end of November so that they finish airing episode
six before the end of December, then I think we could see it during 2018.
Otherwise I think that they would hold it for at least February or March.
You don't see a whole lot of TV series starting in February.
But the other thing that's sort of bridging the gap between season 7-season 8 is Westworld season 2. Which will probably
premiere at the beginning of the summer if not the late spring, so that's May-June.
So I'll talk a little bit more about Westworld season 2 when they release the first teaser.
But if you have any specific bonus video requests, just leave them in the comments below.
There are a couple new cast members that they announced they're looking for, so if you guys want me to do a cast breakdown just
let me know in the comments below. There's a Star Wars trailer
that's dropping tomorrow, so I have some new Rick and Morty coming and that Flash is on Tuesday.
So it's gonna be really busy for the next couple days.
Make sure you click that bell to turn alerts on so you don't miss any of the videos.
Congratulations to the latest DVD giveaway winner Jojo Moon. Please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your contact details.
I'll announce a new winner when I post that next Game of Thrones video.
So while you wait for everything click here for more season eight and you can click here for that Justice League trailer that just dropped.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight.